[Music]
the amazing world of gumball has some of
the most interesting characters ever but
have you ever wondered what they look
like if they were older get ready for
some mind-blowing fan art don't forget
to hit that notification bell to never
miss another video and be sure to check
out our community section for even more
fun now let's check out grown-up gumball
characters are you thinking what I'm
thinking
gumball let's start with the main star
of the show
this blue male cat has absolutely
captured the hearts of many anti refuses
to give them back I don't think it has
anything to do with me my conscience is
clear how adorable is he sure this show
is a huge trip but you have to admit
that the characters are actually super
cute
gumballs full name is gumball Watterson
his age is listed as 12 years old and if
you watched the show you know that he
has quite the imagination but have you
ever wondered what he looked like if he
was slightly older check him out and
this image belongs to Neelu ki from
deviantART and it definitely shows
gumball and is slightly different and
more adult-like form if we're going by
this actual age this would be gumball at
22 what do you think sometimes we forget
that gumballs actually a cat but this
gorgeous drawing makes this very clear
in the reimagined image gumball actually
wears his regular clothing it's very
interesting to see his clothes come to
life we're totally here for an older
gumball Nicole
next on our list is the one in only
Nicole Watterson she's the mother of the
family and someone who's extremely
loving and dedicated to every family
member honestly she's the type of mother
we'd all love to have just like her son
she's also a blue cat but she's much
older than gumball which shows she's
actually older her age is listed as 38
which is quite a lot but check out this
deviantART version of Nicole it was
created by a talented artist that goes
by the name of mousical genius he put a
spin on
Cole that we see on the show and
honestly we're in love with her looks
like an older Nicole would have had a
makeover to be fair that does often
happen to people who go through their
midlife crisis which is definitely in
the age bracket Nicole would be in check
her out although she's still a cat this
image gives her an entirely new
perspective she looks like she could
easily be in an anime and that outfit
it's pretty much the most adorable thing
we've ever seen ah nice
ah nieces gumballs little sister and
honestly she's the most adorable member
of the Watterson family arie gumball
she's just the cutest but have you
noticed how cartoons always make the
youngest members of their families the
most intelligent the four-year-old on a
yeast is no different from someone like
Lisa loud she's definitely able to put
two and two together faster than any of
her family members and we'd love her for
that but check out this amazing
progression chart created by deviant
arts Roni Ramirez it shows what on a
yeast would look like at various stages
of her life and it's honestly pretty
awesome and ten years the four-year-old
on a yeast would be a teenager Juana
Ramirez gave a pretty detailed
description of what Anais would be like
as a team of course she'd be the best
student and she's good at pretty much
everything the artist also states that
onna East would totally begin dating one
of her closest friends to be there this
could totally happen granny Jojo and how
could we possibly forget about the 63
year old granny Jojo granny Jojo is a
pink rabbit even though it's not that
clearly seen because her gigantic
glasses cover up half of her face in
case you're confused
she's Richards mother but more about
Richard in just a bit
granny Jojo is one of a kind and we
absolutely adore her goofy personality
sure she definitely has her problems and
her parenting technique isn't exactly
the best we all know an old person like
that don't we
her character pretty much embodies that
match you from deviantART we imagined
granny Jojo as a slightly older
character
truth be told this granny didn't really
change that much she's still the same
old grumpy character we know and love
looks like this granny Jojo is even
grumpy are we can totally see her in the
retirement home doing nothing but
yelling at people to fix things around
her either way this joint is absolutely
fantastic and totally accurate Richard
speaking of pink rabbits Richard is one
too if the family didn't seem bizarre
just yet it will with Richard he's a
typical childish dad that doesn't really
have everything together it needs to be
way louder to have an effect you can't
blame him though the amazing world of
gumball is just a weirdly bizarre
experience
Richard is 38 years old exactly the same
age as his wife Nicole although he's the
father figure he's not really completely
there but that doesn't mean he's not
awesome TL HDS from deviant art created
a vector version of Richard and honestly
he does look slightly older does he
remind you of granny dodo although we
have a feeling Richard will be different
from granny Jojo when he reaches her age
or at least we hope he doesn't but this
image confirms the fact that Richard is
still just as childish ten years on Kari
the amazing world of gumball wouldn't be
complete without one of our favorite
characters Carrie Kruger is a
transparent ghost and she really is one
of our faves you're supposed to help
them find happiness not ruin their
chances Harry is an emo ghost and
honestly she's one of the most unique
characters you'll ever see in a cartoon
not only is she a ghost but she's also
in her emo phase many of us went through
she's 12 years old in the original show
but check her out as a slightly older
character deviance arts Elsa cameo dot
Braille reimagined Carrie in a unique
way we're pretty sure she's much older
here because she now actually has proper
arms and of course she looks like a
human - we can totally see her as a
horror anime character she can also
enter a person's body and make them do
whatever she wants
how cool is that scary but really cool
leave out this illustration but we love
our
idle image even more all characters
personified okay we all know that the
amazing world of gumball characters are
animals but imagine if they were humans
that would definitely take a few years
to happen right luckily we have talented
artists who are actually able to
reimagine these characters almost
immediately this image belongs to Mike
and Nell from deviantART check it out
how many can you recognise come let us
know in the comments and that's it for
our video don't forget to subscribe to
the things for more videos like this one
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]